The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're
going to hold off just
a little bit on boiling water.
And talk about another
application of integrals,
and we'll get to the witches'
cauldron in the middle.
The thing that I'd like to start
with today is average value.
This is something that I
mentioned a little bit earlier,
and there was a
misprint on the board,
so I want to make sure that we
have the definitions straight.
And also the reasoning straight.
This is one of the most
important applications
of integrals, one of the
most important examples.
If you take the average
of a bunch of numbers,
that looks like this.
And we can view this
as sampling a function,
as we would with
the Riemann sum.
And what I said last
week was that this
tends to this expression
here, which is
called the continuous average.
So this guy is the
continuous average.
Or just the average of f.
And I want to explain that,
just to make sure that we're all
on the same page.
In general, if you
have a function
and you want to
interpret the integral,
our first interpretation
was that it's something
like the area under the curve.
But average value is another
reasonable interpretation.
Namely, if you
take equally spaced
points here, starting
with x_0, x_1, x_2,
all the way up to x_n,
which is the left point b,
and then we have
values y_1, which
is f(x_1); y_2, which is
f(x_2); all the way up
to y_n, which is f(x_n).
And again, the spacing here that
we're talking about is (b-a) /
n.
So remember that spacing,
that's going to be
the connection that we'll draw.
Then the Riemann sum is y_1
through y_n, the sum of y_1
through y_n,
multiplied by delta x.
And that's what tends, as delta
x goes to 0, to the integral.
The only change in
point of view if I
want to write this
limiting property, which
is right above here, the
only change between here
and here is that I want
to divide by the length
of the interval. b - a.
So I will divide by b - a here.
And divide by b - a over here.
And then I'll just check
what this thing actually is.
Delta x / (b-a),
what is that factor?
Well, if we look over here
to what delta x is, if you
divide by b - a, it's 1 / n.
So the factor delta
x / (b-a) is 1 / n.
That's what I put over
here, the sum of y_1
through y_n divided by n.
And as this tends to 0, it's
the same as n going to infinity.
Those are the same things.
The average value
and the integral
are very closely related.
There's only this difference
that we're dividing
by the length of the interval.
I want to give an
example which is
an incredibly simpleminded
one, but it'll
come into play later on.
So let's take the
example of a constant.
And this is, I hope-- will
make you slightly less confused
about what I just wrote.
As well as making
you think that this
is as simpleminded and
reasonable as it should be.
If I check what the average
value of this constant is,
it's given by this relatively
complicated formula here.
That is, I have to
integrate the function c.
Well, it's just the constant c.
And however you do this, as an
antiderivative or as thinking
of it as a rectangle, the
answer that you're going to get
is c here.
So work that out.
The answer is c.
And so the fact that
the average of c
is equal to c, which had better
be the case for averages,
explains the denominator.
Explains the 1 / (b-a) there.
That's cooked up exactly so
that the average of a constant
is what it's supposed to be.
Otherwise we have the
wrong normalizing factor.
We've clearly got a piece
of nonsense on our hands.
And incidentally, it
also explains the 1/n
in the very first formula
that I wrote down.
The reason why this
is called the average,
or one reason why
it's the right thing,
is that if you took the
same constant c, for y
all the way across there n
times, if you divide it by n,
you get back c.
That's what we mean
by average value
and that's why the n is there.
So that was an easy example.
Now none of the examples
that we are going to give
are going to be all
that complicated.
But they will get sort of
steadily more sophisticated.
The second example is going
to be the average height
of a point on a semicircle.
And maybe I'll draw a picture
of the semicircle first here.
And we'll just make it the
standard circle, the unit
circle.
So maybe I should have
called it a unit semicircle.
This is the point negative
1, this is the point 1.
And we're picking
a point over here
and we're going to take the
typical, or the average, height
here.
Integrating with respect to dx.
So sort of continuously
with respect to dx.
Well, what is that?
Well, according to the rule,
it's 1/(b-a) times - sorry,
it's up here in the box.
1/(b-a), the integral
from a to b, f(x) dx.
That's 1 / (+1 - (-1)).
The integral from - 1 to 1,
square root of 1 - x^2, dx.
Right, because the height is
y is equal to-- this is y is
equal to the square
root of 1 - x^2.
And to evaluate this is not
as difficult as it seems.
This is 1/2 times
this quantity here,
which we can
interpret as an area.
It's the area of the semicircle.
So this is the area
of the semicircle,
which we know to be half
the area of the circle.
So it's pi/2.
And so the answer, here the
average height, is pi/4.
Now, later in the class and
actually not in this unit,
we'll actually be
able to calculate
the antiderivative of this.
So in other words, we'll be able
to calculate this analytically.
For right now we just
have the geometric reason
why the value of this is pi/2.
And we'll do that
in the fourth unit
when we do a lot of
techniques of integration.
So here's an example.
Turns out, the average
height of this is pi/4.
Now, the next example
that I want to give
introduces a little
bit of confusion.
And I'm not going to resolve
this confusion completely,
but I'm going to try
to get you used to it.
I'm going to take the
average height again.
But now, with respect
to arc length.
Which is usually denoted theta.
Now, this brings up an extremely
important feature of averages.
Which is that you
have to specify
the variable with respect
to which the average is
taking place.
And the answer will be different
depending on the variable.
So it's not going
to be the same.
Wow, can't spell the
word length here.
Just like the plural of
witches the last time.
We'll work on that.
We'll fix all of our, that's an
ancient Gaelic word, I think.
Lengh.
So now, let me show you that
it's not quite the same here.
It's especially
exaggerated if maybe I
shift this little interval dx
over to the right-hand end.
And you can see that the
little portion that corresponds
to it, which is
the d theta piece,
has a different length
from the dx piece.
And indeed, as you
come down here,
these very short
portions of dx length
have much longer
portions of theta length.
So that the average that
we're taking when we do it
with respect to theta
is going to emphasize
the low values more.
They're going to be
more exaggerated.
And the average should
be lower than the average
that we got here.
So we should expect
a different number.
And it's not going
to be / 4, it's
going to be something else.
Whatever it is, it should
be smaller than pi / 4.
Now, let's set up the integral.
The integral follows
the same rule.
It's just 1 over the length
of the interval times
the integral over the
interval of the function.
That's the integral, but
now where does theta range?
This time, theta
goes from 0 to pi.
So the integral is from 0 to pi.
And the thing we
divide by is pi.
And the integration
requires us to know
the formula for the height.
Which is sin theta.
In terms of theta, of course.
It's the same as
square root of 1 - x^2,
but it's expressed
in terms of theta.
So it's this.
And here's our average.
I'll put this up here.
So that's the formula
for the height.
So let's work it out.
This one, we have the
advantage of being
able to work out because we
know the antiderivative of sin
theta.
It happens with this factor
of pi, it's -cos theta.
And so, that's -1/pi cos
pi-- sorry. (cos pi - cos 0).
Which is -1/pi (-2),
which is 2 / pi.
And sure enough,
if you check it,
you'll see that 2 / pi <
pi / 4, because pi^2 > 8.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is how do I get sin theta.
And the answer is, on this
diagram, if theta is over here,
then this height is this,
and this is the angle theta,
then the height is the sine.
OK.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question
is, what is the first one,
the first one is an
average of height,
of a point on a semicircle and
this one is with respect to x.
So what this
reveals is that it's
ambiguous to say what the
average value of something is,
unless you've explained what
the underlying averaging
variable is.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The next
question is how should you
interpret this value.
That is, what came out
of this calculation?
And the answer is
only sort of embedded
in this calculation itself.
So here's a way
of thinking of it
which is anticipating
our next subject.
Which is probability.
Which is, suppose you
picked a number at random
in this interval.
With equal likelihood,
one place and another.
And then you saw what
height was above that.
That would be the interpretation
of this first average value.
And the second one
is, I picked something
at random on this circle.
And equally likely, any
possible point on this circle
according to its length.
And then I ask what the
height of that point is.
And those are just
different things.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: cos pi,
shouldn't it be 0?
No. cos of-- it's
-1. cos pi is -1.
Cosine, sorry.
No, cos 0 = 1. cos pi = -1.
And so they cancel.
That is, they don't cancel.
It's -1 - 1, which is -2.
Key point.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All
right, let me repeat.
So the question was to
repeat the reasoning
by which I guessed in
advance that probably this
was going to be the relationship
between the average value
with respect to arc length
versus the average value
with respect to this
horizontal distance.
And it had to do with the
previous way this diagram was
drawn.
Which is comparing
an interval in dx
with an interval in theta.
A little section in theta.
And when you're near the top,
they're nearly this same.
That is, it's more
or less balanced.
It's a little curved
here, a little different.
But here it becomes
very exaggerated.
The d theta lengths are much
longer than the dx lengths.
Which means that
importance given
by the theta variable to
these parts of the circle
is larger, relative
to these parts.
Whereas if you look at this
section versus this section
for the dx, they
give equal weights
to these two equal lengths.
But here, with respect to
theta, this is relatively short
and this is much larger.
So, as I say, the
theta variable's
emphasizing the lower parts
of the semicircle more.
That's because this
length is shorter
and this length is longer.
Whereas these two are the same.
It's a balancing act of
the relative weights.
I'm going to say that again
in a different way, and maybe
this will-- The lower part
is more important for theta.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question
is, but shouldn't it
have a bigger value because
it's a longer length.
Never with averages.
Whatever the length is,
we're always dividing.
We're always compensating
by the total.
We have the integral from 0 to
pi, but we're dividing by pi.
Here we had the integral from -1
to 1, but we're dividing by 2.
So we divide by something
different each time.
And this is very,
very important.
It's that the
average of a constant
is that same constant
regardless of which one we did.
So if it were a
constant, we would always
compensate for the length.
So the length never matters.
If it's the integral from 0 to
1,000,000, or 100, let's say,
1/100 c dx, it's just the same.
It's always that, it doesn't
matter how long it is.
Because we compensate.
That's really the difference
between an integral
and an average, is that
we're dividing by the total.
Now I want to introduce another
notion, which is actually
what's underlying these two
examples that I just wrote
down.
And this is by far the one
which you should emphasize
the most in your thoughts.
Because it is much
more flexible,
and is much more typical
of real life problems.
So the idea of a weighted
average is the following.
You take the integral, say
from a to b, of some function.
But now you multiply
by a weight.
And you have to
divide by the total.
And what's the
total going to be?
It's the integral from a to
b of this total weighting
that we have.
Now, why is this
the correct notion?
I'm going to explain
it to you in two ways.
The first is this very
simpleminded thing
that I wrote on the board
there, with the constants.
What we want is the
average value of c to be c.
Otherwise this makes
no sense as an average.
Now, let's just look at
this definition here.
And see that that's correct.
If you integrate c,
from a to b, w(x) dx,
and you divide by the
integral from a to b, w(x) dx,
not surprisingly,
the c factors out.
It's a constant.
So this is c times the integral
a to b, w(x) dx, divided
by the same thing.
And that's why we picked it.
We picked it so that
these things would cancel.
And this would give c.
So in the previous
case, this property
explains the denominator.
And again over here, it
And let me just give you
one more explanation.
Which is maybe a real-life--
pretend real-life example.
You have a stock which you
bought for $10 one year.
And then six months later you
brought some more for $20.
And then you bought
some more for $30.
Now, what's the average
price of your stock?
Well, it depends on how
many shares you bought.
If you bought this many
shares the first time,
and this many shares
the second time,
the third time,
this is the total
amount that you spent.
And the average price is
the total price divided
by the total number of shares.
And this is the discrete analog
of this continuous averaging
process here.
The function f now, so I use w
for weight, the function f now
is the function whose
values are 10, 20 and 30.
And the weightings are
the relative importance
of the different purchases.
So again, these
w_i's are weights.
There was another question.
Out in the audience,
at some point.
Over here, yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Very,
very good point.
So in this numerator here, the
statement is-- in this example,
we factored out c.
But here we cannot
factor out f(x).
That's extremely important
and that is the whole point.
So, in other words, the weighted
average is very interesting
- you have to do two different
integrals to figure it out
in general.
When it happens
that this is c, it's
an extremely boring integral.
Which in fact because,
it's an average,
you don't even have
to calculate at all.
Factor it out and
cancel these things
and never bother to
calculate these two numbers.
So these massive
numbers just cancel.
So it's a very special
property of a constant,
that it factors out.
That was our first discussion,
and now with this example
I'm going to go back to the
heating up of the witches'
cauldron and we'll
use average value
to illustrate the integral that
we get in that context as well.
I remind you, let's see.
The situation with the
witches' cauldron was this.
The first important thing
is that there were-- so this
is the big cauldron here.
This is the one whose
height is 1 meter and whose
width is 2 meters.
And it's a parabola
of revolution here.
And it had about approximately
1600 liters in it.
And this curve was y = x^2.
And the situation
that I described
at the end of last time was
that the initial temperature
was T = 0 degrees Celsius.
And the final
temperature, instead
of being a constant
temperature, we
were heating this guy
up from the bottom.
And it was hotter on the
bottom than on the top.
And the final
temperature was given
by the formula T is equal to
100 minus 30 times the height y.
So at y = 0, at the
bottom, it's 100.
And at the top, T = 70 degrees.
OK, so this is the
final configuration
for the temperature.
And the question was how
much energy do we need.
So, the first observation
here, and this
is the reason for
giving this example,
is that it's
important to realize
that you want to use the
method of disks in this case.
The reason-- So it
doesn't have to do with,
you shouldn't think
of the disks first.
But what you should think
of is the horizontal.
We must use horizontals because
T is constant on horizontals.
It's not constant on verticals.
If we set things up with
shells, as we did last time,
to compute the volume
of this, then T
will vary along the shell.
And we will still have
an averaging problem,
an integral problem along
the vertical portion.
But if we do it this way, T is
constant on this whole level
here.
And so there's no
more calculus involved
in calculating what the
contribution is of any given
level.
So T is constant on horizontals.
Actually, in disguise,
this is that same trick
that we have here.
We can factor constants
out of integrals.
You could view it
as an integral,
but the point is that it's
more elementary than that.
Now I have to set it up for you.
And in order to do
that, I need to remember
what the equation is.
Which is y = x^2.
And the formula for the
total amount of energy
is going to be volume times
the number of degrees.
That's going to be equal to
the energy that we need here.
And so let's add it up.
It's the integral from 0 to 1,
and this is with respect to y.
So the y level goes from 0 to 1.
This top level is y = 1,
this bottom level is y = 0.
And the disk that we get,
this is the point (x, y) here,
is rotated around.
And its radius is x.
So the thickness is dy, and
the area of the disk is pi x^2.
And the thing that
we're averaging
is T. Well, we're
not yet averaging,
we're just integrating it.
We're just adding up the total.
Now I'm just going to plug in
the various values for this.
And what I'm going to get
is T, again, is 100 - 30y.
And this radius is measured
up to this very end.
So x^2 = y.
So this is pi y dy.
And this is the integral that
we'll be able to evaluate.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right.
Well, let's carry this out.
Let's finish off the
calculation here.
Let's see.
This is equal to,
what it it equal to?
Well, I'll put it over here.
It's equal to 50 pi
y ^2 minus-- right,
because this is 100 pi
y, and then there's a 30,
this is 100 pi y - 30 pi
y^2, and I have to take
the antiderivative of that.
So I get 50 pi y^2, and I get
10 pi y^3, evaluated at 0 and 1.
And that is 40 pi.
Now, I spent a
tremendous amount of time
last time focusing on units.
Because I want to tell you how
to get a realistic number out
of this.
And there's a subtle point
here that I pointed out
last time that had to do with
changing meters to centimeters.
I claim that I've
treated those correctly.
So, what we have here
is that the answer
is in degrees, that is
Celsius, times cubic meters.
These are the correct units.
And now, I can translate this
into-- Celsius is spelled
with a C. That's interesting.
Celsius.
I can translate this into units
that you're more familiar with.
So let's try 40 pi
degrees times m^3,
and then do the
conversion factors.
First of all there's one calorie
per degree times a milliliter.
That's one conversion.
And then let's see.
I'm going to have to translate
from centimeters so I have here
(100 cm / m)^3.
So these are the two
conversion factors that I need.
And so, I get 40 pi
10^6, that's 100^3.
And this is in calories.
So how much is this?
Well, it's a little
better, maybe,
to do it in 40 pi *
1,000 kilocalories,
because these are the
ones that you actually
see on your nutrition
labels of foods.
And so this number
is around 125 or so.
Let's see, is that about right?
Let's make sure I've
got these numbers right.
Yeah, this is about 125.
40 times pi.
And so one candy bar-- This
is a Halloween example, so.
One candy bar is about
250 kilocalories.
So this is half a candy bar.
So the answer to our question
is that it takes 500 candy bars
to heat up this thing.
OK, so that's our example.
Now, yeah.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What does
the integral give us?
This integral is-- the integral
represents the following
things.
So the question is, what
does this integral give us.
So here's the integral.
Here it is, rewritten so
that it can be calculated.
And what this integral is giving
us is the following thing.
You have to imagine
the following idea.
You've got a little
chunk of water in here.
And you're going to
raise is from 0 degrees
all the way up to whatever
the target temperature is.
And so that little milliliter
of water, if you like,
has to be raised from
0 to some number which
is a function of the height.
It's something between
70 and 100 degrees.
And the one right
above it also has
to be raised to a temperature,
although a slightly
different temperature.
And what we're doing with the
integral is we're adding up
all of those degrees and the
calorie represents how much it
takes, one calorie
represents how much
it takes to raise by 1
degree 1 milliliter of water.
One cubic centimeter of water.
That's the definition
of a calorie.
And we're adding it up.
So in other words, each of
these cubes is one thing.
And now we have to add it up
over this massive thing, which
is 1600 liters.
And we have a lot of
different little cubes.
And that's what we did.
When we glommed
them all together.
That's what the integral
is doing for us.
Other questions.
Now I want to connect this
with weighted averages
before we go on.
Because that was the reason why
I did weighted averages first.
I'm going to compute also the
average final temperature.
So, final because this
is the interesting one,
the average starting
temperature's very boring,
it's 0.
The average final
temperature is-- individually
the temperatures are different.
And the answer here
is it's the integral
from 0 to 1 of T pi y dy
divided by the integral
from 0 to 1 of pi y dy.
So this is the
total temperature,
weighted appropriately to
the volume of water that's
involved at that
temperature, divided
by the total volume of water.
And we computed
these two numbers.
The number in the numerator
is what we call 40 pi.
And the number in the
denominator, actually this
is easier than what we
did last time with shells;
you can just look at
this and see that it's
the area under a triangle.
It's pi / 2.
And so the answer
here is 80 degrees.
This is the average temperature.
Note that this is
a weighted average.
The weighting here is different
according to the height.
The weighting factor is pi y.
That's the weighting factor.
And that's not surprising.
When y is small, there's
less volume down here.
Up above, those are
more important volumes,
because there's more water
up at the top of the cauldron
than there is down at the
bottom of the cauldron.
If you compare this to
the ordinary average,
if you take the
maximum temperature
plus the minimum
temperature, divided by 2,
that would be (100 + 70) / 2.
You would get 85 degrees.
And that's bigger.
Why?
Because the cooler
water is on top.
And the actual average, the
correct weighted average,
is lower than this fake average.
Which is not the true
average in this context.
All right so the weighting
is that the thing
is getting fatter near the top.
So now I'm going to do another
example of weighted average.
And this example is also
very much worth your while.
It's the other
incredibly important one
in interpreting integrals.
And it's a very, very simple
example of a function f.
The weightings
will be different,
but the function f, will be
of a very particular kind.
Namely, the function f will
be practically a constant.
But not quite.
It's going to be
a constant on one
interval, and then
0 on the rest.
So we'll do those
weighted averages now.
And this subject is
called probability.
In probability, what
we do, so I'm just
going to give some
examples here.
I'm going to pick a point in
quotation marks - at random.
In the region y < x < 1 - x^2.
That's this shape here.
Well, let's draw
it right down here.
For now.
So, somewhere in here.
Some point, (x, y).
And then I need to tell
you, according to what
this random really means.
This is proportional
to area, if you like.
So area inside of this section.
And then the question that we're
going to answer right now is,
what is the chance that - or,
it's usually called probability
- that x > 1/2.
Let me show you
what's going on here.
And this is always the case
with things in probability.
So, first of all, we
have a name for this.
This is called the
probability that x > 1/2.
And so that's what it's
called in our notation here.
And what it is,
is the probability
is always equal to the
part divided by the whole.
It's a ratio just like
the one over there.
And which is the part
and which is the whole?
Well, in this picture, the
whole is the whole parabola.
And the part is the
section x > 1/2.
And it's just the ratio
of those two areas.
Let's write that down.
That's the integral from
1/2 to 1 of (1 - x^2) dx,
divided by the integral
from -1 to 1, (1 - x^2) dx.
And again, the weighting
factor here is 1 - x^2.
And to be a little bit
more specific here,
the starting point a = -1
and the endpoint is +1.
So this is P(x < 1/2).
And if you work it out, it turns
out to be 5/18, we won't do it.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What we're trying
to do with probability.
So I can't repeat your question.
But I can try to
say-- because it was
a little bit too complicated.
But it was not correct, OK.
What we're taking is, we
have two possible things
that could happen.
Either, let's put it this way.
Let's make it a gamble.
Somebody picks a point
in here at random.
And we're trying
to figure out what
your chances are of winning.
In other words, the chances the
person picks something in here
versus something in there.
And the interesting thing is,
so what percent of the time
do you win.
The answer is it's
some fraction of 1.
And in order to
figure that out, I
have to figure out
the total area here.
Versus the total of the entire,
all the way from -1 to 1,
the beginning to the end.
So in the numerator, I put
success, and in the denominator
I put all possibilities.
So that-- Right?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And that's the
interpretation of this.
So maybe I didn't
understand your question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah, why is 1 -
x^2. the weighting factor.
That has to do with how you
compute areas under curves.
The curve here is y = 1 - x^2.
And so, in order to calculate
how much area is between 1/2
and 1, I have to integrate.
That's the
interpretation of this.
This is the area
under that curve.
This integral.
And the denominator's the
area under the whole thing.
OK, yeah.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Ah.
Yikes.
It was supposed to be the
same question as over here.
Thank you.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This has something
to do with weighting factors.
Here's the weight factor.
Well, it's the
relative importance
from the point of view
of this probability
of these places versus those.
That is, so this is a weighting
factor because it's telling me
that in some sense this number
5/18-- actually that makes me
think that this number
is probably wrong.
Well, I'll let you
calculate it out.
It looks like it should
be less than 1/4 here,
because this is 1/4
of the total distance
and there's a
little less in here
than there is in the middle.
So in fact it probably should
be less than 1/4, the answer.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The equation
of the curve is 1 - x^2.
The reason why
it's the weighting
factor is that we're
interpreting-- The question
has to do with the
area under that curve.
And so, this is showing us how
much is relatively important
versus how much is not.
This is-- These parts
are relatively important,
these parts are less important.
According to area.
Because we've said
that area is the way
we're making the choice.
So I don't have
quite enough time
to tell you about
my next example.
Instead, I'm just
going to tell you
what the general formula is.
And we'll do our
example next time.
I'll tell you what
it's going to be.
So here's the general
formula for probability here.
We're going to imagine that
we have a total range which
is maybe going
from a to b, and we
have some intermediate
values x_1 and x_2,
and then we're going to try
to compute the probability
that some variable that
we picked at random
occurs between x_1 and x_2.
And by definition, we're
saying that it's an integral.
It's the integral from x_1
to x_2 of the weight dx,
divided by the integral
all the way from a to b.
Of the weight.
So, again, this is the
part divided by the whole.
And the relationship between
this and the weighted average
that we had earlier was
that the function f f(x)
is kind of a strange function.
It's 0 and 1.
It's just-- The
picture, if you like,
is that you have this
weighting factor.
And it's going from a to b.
But then in between
there, we have the part
that we're interested in.
Which is between x_1 and x_2.
And it's the ratio of this
inner part to the whole thing
that we're interested in.
Tomorrow I'm going to try
to do a realistic example.
And I'm going to
tell you what it is,
but we'll take it up tomorrow.
I told you it was
going to be tomorrow,
but we still have
a whole minute,
so I'm going to tell
you what the problem is.
So this is going to be a
target practice problem.
You have a target
here and you're
throwing darts at this target.
And so you're throwing
darts at this target.
And somebody is standing
next to the dartboard.
Your little brother is standing
next to the dartboard here.
And the question
is, how likely you
are to hit your little brother.
So this will, let's see.
You'll see whether
you like that or not.
Actually, I was
the little brother.
So, I don't know which
way you want to go.
We'll go either way.
We'll find out next time.